apple is about to change the world and
Usher in a new era next week at WWDC
revealing literally the most complicated
Apple product ever as I'll show you in
this video and don't just take my word
for it Apple just put out this tweet
saying a new era begins so they're very
confident that they're about to change
the world not only that but there are a
bunch of other hints and leaks that
prove apple is 100
releasing their headset at WWDC
including Apple's blog posts on their
developer website titled code new worlds
which could only mean one thing VR but
the best part of all of this is that
Ross young revealed the specs of Apple's
new headset which I'll explain in a
minute but first let's get into the
leaks just the other day yaroslav Beck
tweeted this hinting that June 5th would
be awesome even including a pair of
glasses which can really only mean the
VR headset at WWDC and if you don't know
who jaroslav is he's the co-founder of
beat saber probably the most popular VR
game ever now getting into more leaks an
iOS Developer was able to trick Apple's
App Store Connect into showing the VR
headsets xros operating system name
which was leaked by Mark German and
other sources quite a while back Mark
grooming himself also recently tweeted
that he expect Apple to focus on three
things at WWDC several new Macs the
mixed reality headset and new software
with him expecting this to be one of
Apple's longest Keynotes ever and seeing
as Apple's headset will handle both VR
and AR I think it's going to be
incredibly complex which was actually
something that the information reported
on just yesterday they said that the
headset is the most complicated Hardware
product Apple has ever created due to
its unconventional curved shape thinness
and ultra light weight which has
resulted in its expected three thousand
dollar price tag on top of that they
also mentioned that Apple actually had
to create bent motherboards in order to
fit the design perfectly to make it even
thinner which sounds incredibly complex
now that makes me very excited because
it seems like apple is about to make
basically the best VR headset ever
created in all time and all while being
the most high-end in terms of the specs
as well and probably the software too
apparently the information viewed
internal digital renders of the device
and explained it as a piece of curved
glass with edges wrapped in a smooth
aluminum frame appearing slightly
thicker than an iPhone which sounds
absolutely mind-blowing so thankfully
Ian zelbo created some new renders based
on all of this info but first I've gotta
shout out our partner bandwork known for
their high quality Apple watch bands and
other leather accessories handmade in
Germany right here in front of me I have
three excellent bands including this
nice green genuine cordovan leather
Zurich band and their dark brown Napa
leather Berlin with high quality
titanium Hardware but my favorite is
this very unique stainless steel band
that looks and feels super premium with
its butterfly clasp and it also comes in
a darker anthracite color as well so
check them all out by using the link
below and use code maxtech 23 to get a
free one ounce leather cream with your
premium band from band work as you can
see the headset looks absolutely
beautiful he packed in vents for airflow
a crown and button for controls like on
the airpods max microphone grills and
antenna bands as well as this braided
strap crowd which seems to use the same
material as Apple's homepod or maybe
it's something new that's even softer
and then within that shroud Ian imagined
how the lenses might look with their
covers with some glowing light coming
from them but of course we don't really
know what it's going to look like until
we see it next week and now let's get
into the massive leaks from Ross young
explaining all of the display specs
apparently there's going to be two 1.41
inch displays which use micro OLED
technology which is extremely expensive
with an insane quality of 4 000 pixels
per inch and 5 000 nits of brightness
now that ppi is absolutely mind-blowing
because Apple's retina displays have a
pixels per inch of just
281 which is what their high-end 6K Pro
display xdr gets with the best PBIS
usually getting to around
460 like on the iPhone 14 pro so 4 000
PPI on the headset sounds insane and
it's gonna make sure that you're not
gonna notice any pixels at all even
though the display is going to be right
in front of your eyes now Ross young
gave us even more detail saying that it
should have 4K resolution per eye to get
the 4000 PPI and just for extra context
Sony's new psvr2 has a PPI of around 800
nowhere near Apple's new headset on top
of that the 5000 nits of peak brightness
is also incredible compared to only
around
265 Nets on the psvr too this basically
means that Apple's headset will be a
massive innovation in display technology
allowing for experiences that aren't
possible with any other product in the
world so now that we have those specs
the high priced is actually making a
whole lot more sense however there was a
leaked bill of materials that showed a
bunch of different components and the
prices for them totaling to around
fourteen hundred dollars or around
sixteen hundred with shipping costs
included that Source also claimed that
Apple would try to make this a
not-for-profit product in order to lower
the initial cost so potentially it might
be close to two thousand dollars but if
they want to go the profit route it may
be as much as three thousand now the
only downside of the headset will be
that it requires you to carry an
external battery pack which is connected
with a single magnetic connection which
Ian zelbo showed off in his renders now
this is something that other companies
have done in the past like the DJI
goggles 2 which requires an external
battery in order to save weight and make
it more comfortable so I'm actually glad
that Apple went with this route instead
of making the head it's an even more
heavy and putting a strain on your head
and now let's finally finish off with
the features and apps that apple is
planning to bring to their headset
according to leaks from Mark German
right off the bat you're gonna have the
ability to run most of Apple's existing
iPad apps in mixed reality which blends
AR and VR including books camera
contacts FaceTime files freeform home
mail Maps messages music notes photos
reminders Safari stocks TV and weather
now imagine how that's going to work on
the headset on top of that you're going
to be able to run thousands of existing
third-party iPad apps from the App Store
with no extra work it's just gonna run
like Rosetta for the Mac there's going
to be a new Wellness app focused on
meditation featuring immersive Graphics
calming sounds and voiceovers which
actually sounds kind of cool putting you
into a more call mood there's even going
to be a new portal for watching sports
in virtual reality as part of Apple's
push into streaming live games and news
which is kind of insane there's also
going to be a large gaming Focus
including top tier titles from existing
third-party Developers for Apple's other
devices and that might actually be why
we saw hideo Kojima near Apple's
headquarters just earlier this month
there's also going to be a feature to
use the headset as an external monitor
for a connected Mac there's going to be
Advanced video conferencing and virtual
meeting rooms with realistic avatars
ideally making users feel like they're
interacting in the same place there's
going to be new collaboration tools via
the freeform app that let users work on
Virtual whiteboards and go over material
together just imagine that you're in a
room with avatars riding on a whiteboard
project at the same time just insane
there's going to be a new VR focused
Fitness Plus experience for working out
while wearing the headset that sounds
absolutely awesome and very useful but
that feature might not come until a
little bit later now here's a really
cool one you're going to be able to
watch videos while immersed in a virtual
environment such as a desert scene or in
the sky that is absolutely mind-blowing
imagine you have a nice environment and
just a big screen right in front of your
eyes and with all of that users are
going to be able to operate the headset
in several different ways including by
hand and eye control and Siri and it's
also going to work with connected
keyboards or controls from other Apple
devices now imagine using your eyes to
control things within the headset that
sounds absolutely insane and then on top
of all of that there's going to be apps
from third-party developers as well well
with apple unveiling a software
development kit and Mac based headset
simulator to help developers make
awesome apps so with all that said I
truly think that apple is about to
change the world with the VR headset the
only question is how many people are
actually going to be able to afford it
during these Hard Times hopefully Apple
makes some kind of payment plan to make
it a lot easier to buy one of these I
guess we're gonna have to find out in
less than one week at WWDC so if you're
as excited as I am go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe so you
don't miss out on our WWDC videos thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next one
foreign